I I somehow think liquid sword somehow
does it is like the most somehow become
the most underrated Wu-Tang album ever
because I feel like it always gets like
[__] like yes like trumped when people
talk about like only Built for Cuban
links or 36 Chambers I'm like I don't
know Liquid Swords Liquid Swords is
amazing I just recently went back and
listened to it front to back so [__]
good man amazing album and it does
you're absolutely right I think that's
also because jizz is just very he's very
reserved yeah he's an introvert he
didn't have as big a personality as
absolutely as the other guys absolutely
that might be it too yeah I think that's
a lot of it too shout out to the Rizzo
man you ever tap in with a reason no I
met him recently
um but I never tapped him with him like
musically which it would be a dream come
true for sure absolutely I also feel
like he doesn't do a lot so be like if
you get a recipe exactly exactly what
are we doing here facts see that's like
like mugs like mugs
he posted I don't know it had to be a
year ago now but he posted one day like
yo I just found mad old dad tapes from
the 90s of my Beats whoa I hit him
immediately like yeah
send me some Joy he sent me recently he
sent me like you're supposed you're
supposed to come on my show soon he's
got I'm coming out yeah yeah he's I text
the guy back on my bucket of this [__]
please bring him by and I and we're I
think we're like neighbors because he
walks his dog on my street all the time
and I've never stopped and been like
yo mugs why because I just think it'd be
super weird bro the mugs has an ill
Mystique about him bro in his studio is
like in our neighborhood so stupid it's
in Burbank because it looks like it
because I when we would just come here I
was like this mug Studio I could walk
there in like six minutes from my front
door okay it's just this black building
next to this popular Mexican restaurant
and it just the soul assassins A's on it
and I remember I hit my boy I'm like yo
it's mug studio in Burbank yeah it's
right there on Victory I was like yeah
that's crazy yeah legendary [__] and
when you go bro it's like a time machine
in there he got all like well once I
interview him I'm gonna try to I Wanna
my goal is to become friends so we can
like walk our dogs together
and then I can be like hey man can I
come and check the studio out yo that
that's that studio I recorded that last
time I was out here I was like bro this
[__] is like so you guys five Beats from
him from the dats from the dads the old
joints some of them are not even
complete but he's like yeah if you [__]
with this I'll finish it up that's fire
I got you so have you uh tapped him
without yet Alchemist ow yo unheard
story right here unheard story nobody
knows this story
probably five six years ago
I [__] go to Al's crib
pick out a Beat
write it right there on the spot as I'm
writing the first verse
West Side gun comes in big body best is
already there
oh that's gonna be a cool hangout you
and big body best in the same place oh
my God yo [__]
[__] Conway comes in so I'm in I'm in
there's a center like an island in the
kitchen I'm writing it but these
[__] is having wild
conversations I got some other [__] on
my mind that just happened that same day
where I was like I really don't not in
the mood to write but I wrote These two
verses I put it on the beat
we did it after the next day both of us
hit each other was like um I think we
could do something better and I was like
yeah I think we could do something
better too yeah so let's just scrap it
and that's the only time I ever worked
The Alchemist and I'm so tight that that
happened because Alchemist is like one
of my favorites one of the girls
producers and I'm just it just was like
a [__] tornado of [__] that was going
on in my life and literally right there
while I was writing that just took me
off my game where I was just like we
could do better situation up yeah if you
and big body best are in the same place
is it like just like an aggravated
assault felony charge like in the air
absolutely just floating around
absolutely that same time I think the
next day me and him drove to Vegas
together and just oh my God out to Vegas
Vegas with you two would be out because
you're sober now but like you're also
you yeah yeah facts I would just be like
yo can we go [__] with prostitutes like
you know my favorite thing to do in
Vegas is like because I used to live
there
like you know I'd like just I'd like to
embarrass old men with their horse
so like uh like I like walk up to like a
dude who's like with like you know
obvious prostitute you know like I'm
like GFE get the GFE going huh
girlfriend experience gfp for the hundo
100 roses
to Backpage those were the days 100
roses ah man
um what for you this album is all you
also you I feel like you're a pretty
vulnerable guy in terms of like a lot of
people know a lot about like a lot of
low points in your life a lot of you
know your battles of addiction and
obviously being incarcerated but on this
album you kind of shared a little bit
about your family life yeah your Pops
passed away from AIDS yeah HIV he hit
contract he contracted HIV from needle
needles yeah yeah yeah luckily me and my
moms didn't get it
um and yeah passed away when I was four
years old damn and that was probably I
mean I know you talk about kind of like
having a hard time forgiving him
yeah nah that was that was I said that
was gone okay okay
I don't really have that man I have like
two three memories about my father and
one of them is like etched in my mind
it's like like a movie scene now in my
mind when I think about it I remember
walking through the the funeral the the
funeral home my mother bringing me by
the hand and kissing them on his
forehead in this casket that's like one
of the only memories I have in my [__]
yeah yeah facts that's crazy so yeah
yeah that happens and you're kind of
like forced to like grow up and be like
that'll be a gotta be the man of the
house from early you know what I'm
saying so it is what it is these things
make me who I am you know